the Joe Rogan experience you know what I
mean if you're an elk you don't want to
get caught in a valley with some wolves
that shits rough that's a rough way to
go I was talking to your buddy Jeff
earlier about that um like you got a
choice right you go you're gonna of
course hypothetically you had a choice
you know you're gonna get mauled by a
bear a gorilla or die by wolf or tiger
what do you choose I'll take the gorilla
all day because I think he's just gonna
beat your ass I don't think he's gonna
kill you because I don't think I don't
think he wants to eat you but like the
premise of the question is you're gonna
die hmm
yeah then the tiger cuz the Tigers gonna
get your neck and kill you quick that's
that's my choice yeah I think so I just
see the video of the tiger chasing the
dudes on the motorbike no oh
in India it's horrific dudes driving on
this road yeah in this wildlife preserve
and this tiger comes full clip chasing
them out of the jungle and just bails
off at the last second I just can't
catch up it should it's [ __ ] horrific
they're so fast like what do you do
right can you do everything you can do
once you have a gun you're so weak it's
not much you can do but then when you
think about that they're like you think
about Africa you think about anything
about these places where lions and
tigers exist and people have existed
since the beginning of time mm-hmm at
some point someone had to win that right
just just numbers just population
numbers here's the video check this [ __ ]
out you're gonna freak out I don't need
to see her Jamie here it is so these
guys are on this thing this thing just
oh he just tried he tried now the reason
why this is significant is because in
India Tigers eat people all the [ __ ]
time they eat them all the time like
there's Tigers that target human beings
there's a place in India called the
Sunderbans
and the Sunderbans is it's near this
river that they think that one of the
reasons where the Tigers are so
irritable is that they're drinking this
river water and the river water has a
high degree of salt in it high level
salt and so they're irritated all the
time yeah this is in the agony and
they're particularly vicious and over
the last 200
years tigers have killed more than
300,000 human beings in this one part of
India why do you still live there like
I'm giving work you know I'm giving them
I'm giving that place to the Tigers
I see that I see that video and I
imagine being that guy on that bike and
like I you know what a bike seat is like
right yeah you could imagine being on a
bike seat with like what I'm [ __ ]
myself yeah you know if you have any
[ __ ] in your body it's gonna come out
like that's it there's no way you win
that you know no way you win that no day
no you don't win the only win by being
on a motorcycle and getting away the
fact they got a video of it though yeah
how do you hey I hope you had a GoPro I
just like riding hey they listen they
get they get got all the time all the
time especially in India India I think
is the worst place in the world for
Tiger and human interactions I don't get
that like other tigers in India bigger
Tigers yeah I know it doesn't matter the
size like they're even like 300 or 500
pounds or something like that I think
the biggest Tigers are in Siberia okay
but think that's the case usually with
mammals what happens is the like the
same species when they're in a hotter
climate tend to be smaller depends on
the animal obviously then they are in
the colder climates it's something that
has something to do with preserving body
temperature like deer for instance like
if you get a white-tailed deer from
Texas it's much smaller than a
white-tailed deer from Saskatchewan yeah
it's the same species but way up north
if they just it's just colder and they
go grow they'll go like 300 pounds up
there
whereas like a big whitetail in Texas
like half that size yeah yeah the the
that's people to certain places with
people yeah the mountain guy from Game
of Thrones that [ __ ] yes they
had a controversial moment at the end of
last year into this year they had a
tiger that was known for killing 13
people or more and so they had a shoot
to kill target on it you know and I
guess they someone got it
and people are mad people were mad it
killed 13 people and people are mad that
someone killed it people are just
[ __ ] weak they just so soft what if
you got the wrong Tiger [ __ ] him [ __ ]
them all kill whatever anyone that you
get a chance to kill that's close enough
to kill you kill him man I think I I key
I can't get that that video of the tiger
chasing that that by got him alright cuz
like like that's another thing those
things they're so coordinated that thing
at full speed can take a swipe at that
rack tire and then you're screwed like
what do you do cuz you like what's your
first reaction gonna be like get up and
try and get back on the bike there's
nothing you can do there's nothing you
do there's no way you get the bike going
in time the tiger would be on you so
fast maybe they can run they could
probably run 40 miles an hour those
[ __ ] yes yeah and it's probably 400
pounds
500 pounds 400 pounds of something an
animal that's 400 something pounds and
runs at twice the speed of Usain Bolt
how is that fair I mean that's why
there's not a million deer you know the
reason why millions in that same spot
yeah because of those Tigers they need
them you know I was in lanai which is
one of the smaller islands in Hawaii
huntin access deer an access deer were
given to King Kamehameha of Hawaii like
in the 1800's and when we were over
there you know you bow hunt these things
and I'm telling you you've never seen a
deer move this fast yeah the reason why
they're so fast is they evolved to get
away from Tigers so when they see you
there but they make these noise like
bait and then they [ __ ] scatter yeah
they're so fast you like it's hilarious
to watch like wow they're so fast when
you say that like my brain just starts
doing the math and I'm like like of
course the ones that got caught by the
Tigers with a slower one yeah so like
the fastest ones are mating yeah like
yeah I can only imagine it's it's kind
of like
Olympic sprinter mm female Olympic
sprinter marries a running back yeah
they have a kid whoo yeah
[Applause]